voltado a todos pois de fato eu sou
milene matos é possível que tenham visto
meu nome ultimamente na comunicação
social
por causa deste galardão longe porque
luz um prodígio acadêmico
o meu currículo e os jornais assim o
fazem querer torcer e de fato o segundo
currículo é verdade mas não é nada disso
que você quer falar eu quero falar
enquanto milene de trazer por casa entre
aspas enquanto pessoa que acredita que
saber só tem sentido quando
transformamos em ações práticas quanto
têm utilidade plásticos hoje e os
cientistas devem sentir que têm
utilidade para as pessoas e portanto
saber deve ser convertido em ações em
ações práticas sempre nos giros é
preciso arregaçar as mangas e o terreno
portanto o segundo com licença eu vou
pro campo santo na china o chumbo no
período em que o bullying eo racismo era
uma realidade e por causa dos orçamentos
portugueses chegarem bacalhau eu não
tinha muitos amigos dos meus amigos é um
dos meus irmãos e nós éramos felizes os
trechos nos nossos mundos de fantasia
éramos felizes com hora marcada essa
hora é quando estávamos aos 3 na rua
nós não podemos estar em casa podemos
mas não queremos que nosso pai não
estava nós de fazer isso que estão nos
dizer e nos fazer sentir todas as
maneiras não gostava de nós e nós
preferimos ir brincar na rua e isto
dizer que brincava na rua às vezes é
fria - vejo -15 graus de temperatura
mas ele brincava nos riachos e com os
escorpiões de com os bichos
e foi com sei um pouco forçada mas foi
aí que comecei a observar o mundo
natural e como funcionava a nossa idéia
não tinha muitas vacas tenha criado as
vacas e havia muitos pratos com uma
cerca eletrificada limitar esses prazos
portanto podemos dizer que o choque
fazia parte constante em nossa vida
nós também não temos muitas
possibilidades portanto não tínhamos
muitos livros em casa mas os 13 anos a
vida de conhecimento e portanto
rapidamente esgotados os livros da
biblioteca da escola tanto tempo passou
e viríamos história viver outro choque
quando os nossos países se viram
necessário para portugal e foi um choque
cultural em que nós vivemos numa europa
futurista não é pós modernista da
moderna e vemos uma aldeia do interior
de portugal onde as pessoas andavam
descalços as pessoas mais velhas porque
sabiam ler e para nós foi bastante
difícil também de vida daquela
maternidade e pluricultural idade um
símbolo para o mal de 6 onde só vimos
senhores de idade assistidas de preto
com bigode foi complicada
e como no meu caso eu falava mal
português portanto também tive que me
adaptar é aquela nova realidade mais uma
vez procurava o mundo natural para me
inspirar para isolar para filosofar eua
embora na altura não soubesse o que é
que isso era questionava quem lava muito
mundo natural nos com dário lembro-me
com o professor não de ciências mas
vamos fazer um estudo sobre um problema
ambiental então no meu grupo decidimos
fazer o inventário das lixeiras desta
minha onda é muito bem vindo de avião
mas quantas lixeiras fizemos uns
cartazes a dizer não à poluição acho que
esse foi meu primeiro texto ambiental na
altura não há poluição e tentamos
explicar às pessoas que os
comportamentos não podiam prosseguir e
como chocou neste episódio fui sentir
que as pessoas estavam completamente
desinteressados não chocou tanto lixo
como aquela aceitação da ignorância inda
hoje um show que essa aceitação de
lembrança e principalmente daquela
aldeia e não é só o lixo ali é normal
haver alcoolismo violência episódios de
incesto tudo era aceitável nos
procuraram corrigir esse comportamento
de contribuir para que não existia
hoje felizmente tudo isso mudou o tempo
passou no final do meu projeto
licenciatura am
eu fiz um estudo com as aves aqui no
campus da unir
a cidade de aveiro no seguimento desse
trabalho os meus orientadores propuseram
fazer um estágio na mata nacional do
buçaco na altura matando é o que hoje
era pouco conhecida e sobre a fauna os
animais nunca tenha havido um estudo
verdadeiramente científico então eu
sentia orgulhosa e fui lá visitar a nota
e logo na primeira visita eu fiquei
bastante impressionada com a beleza ea
riqueza da mata e ele então fiz esse meu
estágio mas não limitaria as águas
logo nesse ano eu fiz a catalogação de
todos os vertebrados que ali existiam
tinha entretanto candidatado a um
doutoramento que foi aprovado um
doutoramento totalmente financiado na
amazônia era um jovem bióloga era o
sonho não é mais aquele estágio percebi
que havia tanto por fazer cá havia
tantos holofotes apontados amazônia e
sim também é importante mas quem é que
apontou um holofote para nossa
biodiversidade aqui na região centro do
país 31 significar e contribuir o melhor
que eu pudesse expressa biodiversidade
já agora pergunto quem já foi à mata do
buçaco
há muitas pessoas que vão a chocar
dessas nossas visitas a nota conheceram
a mata conhece e mata do buçaco o risco
de dizer sempre fez isso é
sustentabilidade ninguém que acha que
não conhece é porque na verdade até aqui
o ponto ninguém conhecia ainda hoje há
muito trabalho a ferramenta para fazer a
nota ficou verdadeiramente conhecida
quando foram feitos estudos a maioria
deles aqui pela o apro colegas da
botânica da fauna da história da
arquitetura que se debruçaram sobre
aquilo cal que tem tanto para proteger e
tanto para nos ensinar
então foi esse conhecimentos científicos
sobre aquilo ecossistema em particular
que despertou a consciência de muitos
para a necessidade de preservar a área e
foi assim que nasceu a fundação mata do
buçaco enquanto entidade gestora tudo e
disciplinar bom número ao estádio eu eu
registei a presença de 150 espécies de
vertebrados escolares para quem não é da
área não diz nada mas posso garantir que
é muito muito
mal 150 espécies incluindo espécies que
só ocorre nesta região do mundo espécies
raras protegidas
a título de exemplo nós temos lá é
manter uma área pequena ter cerca de um
quilômetro quadrado por tanto em termos
espaciais é bastante pequena mas naquele
espaço tão pequeno temos 10 das nossas
17 espécies de anfíbios cá em portugal
podemos também a observar a 15 espécies
de morcegos das 25 que existem tudo
portugal portanto que o parceiro será
rico seria impressionante mas para saber
se de fato ela tinha comparar com outros
locais e esse foi o tema do meu
doutoramento foi comparar a riqueza da
mata do buçaco com o duto já vitais
dominantes naquela região am geográfica
e fato comprovou sua expressão que nós
carinhosamente os anos aqui no aek euros
o do saco é um oásis de biodiversidade
descobrimos os seus altos valores de
conservação ano trazendo também percebi
que não é só mata do sap também aquela
agricultura tradicional a só tinhas não
é são muito importantes são amplas para
as espécies sensíveis precisam de um
local para viver tudo muito lindo mas
foi isso que disputou ter argumentos
científicos e técnicos para poder nos
candidatar a fundos europeus e terminais
financeiros e humanos para pôr a mata no
mapa fascinante impressionante
espetáculo mas nem tudo foram rosas este
doutoramento foi preso de seis anos
particularmente difícil para mim foi um
quilo acima de tudo muita solidão porque
o seu estudo estes grupos todos os
animais
uma pessoa sozinha e foi um projeto
inédito em portugal quer dizer que eu
tenho está no campo antes do nascer do
sol para observar os dados continuarem a
estudar os ratinhos as raposas até 60 e
80 ainda está a estudar mesmo sexo
tanto a economia conforme fosse possível
e continuava a trabalhar
vivia nas condições um pouco complicadas
porque eu não tinha água quente entre o
rap o cabelo tinha material para
carregar e podem imaginar na altura eu
tinha 50 quilos gerar uma garota
e que já foi o saco pode imaginar o que
é carregar sacos material livro de
máquinas josé do pinho do markeitng até
à cruz alta um dos episódios que me
marcou foi a primeira vez que eu tenho
que fazer um determinado tipo de
amostragem da cruz alta em que eu tinha
que provar a água então eu com 50 quilos
carreguei durante um quilômetro de
calorias um banho de 40 litros de água
eu tinha duas hipóteses ou não fazia o
carregava rio
eu escolhi carregar o carro achei que
valeria a pena e acho que valeu bom
quando eu seria levar o estudo para fora
da área da mata concelho contactar com
pessoas que achavam que eu estava linda
terra em terra fazer a não saber o que
eles achavam que estava outra
instituição ou vender droga ou estava a
faltar alguma casa porque na altura não
se falava ciência naquela região do país
portanto não baterem eu tinha que
explicar o que estava a fazer e consegue
contactar com as pessoas e explicar
envolvê las e percebi o quanto elas
desconheciam da realidade que as rodeava
então eu achei que era importante
transmitir já estava numa região tão
rica das mais ricas da europa em termos
de biodiversidade e preferi envolvê las
em assinalar as valas comigo ao campo
para verem o que estavam eu estava a
observar e foi esta ideia de partilha
que nasceu o serviço educativo da mata
nacional do buçaco
já no âmbito do meu pós doutoramento em
comunicação de ciência e serviços
educativos sempre pretendeu inclusivo
multidisciplinar e e inter-geracional
aberto a todos sendo matou um
laboratório vivo eu quis também fazer um
laboratório da educação devidamente
fundamentado com o método científico é
fácil chegar à área com crianças e
explicar já matemática química física
biologia história mas também as letras
das artes filosofia tudo isso com base
nos recursos naturais e na ciência
nós fazemos a facilitação do ensino
escolar ao ar livre sensibilizando
também para a importância da preservação
do meio ambiental mas também recebemos
na mata públicos que talvez não fossem
esperar ver ali
ao falar do idosos como podem ver alguns
já de idade avançada e sofala pessoas
com deficiência física ou mental jovens
delinquentes e também reclusos
uma das coisas que eu gosto de fazer é o
várias pessoas para o campo nos jogos
diz lembrando do episódio de uma senhora
do luso em que ela foi ã o nestas nossas
atividades e principalmente as noturnas
gosta de explicar a realidade dos bichos
que dos quais as pessoas têm medo 70 em
homs centro banias morcegos é isso que
eu gosto de provocar as pessoas para
fazer refletir sobre o património
natural no fim de uma dessas
experiências noturnas
uma senhora chegou o homem agarrou nas
mãos com quase enfim com lágrimas nos
olhos é o mesmo a menina eu vivi aqui
toda a minha vida eu sou a solução foi
aqui na china criada eu achava que
conhecia a mata usa a mesma boca da mata
hoje eu penso eu não conhecia nada não
sabia o que estava a ver isso pra mim
foi incrível e marcou uma e eu achei que
ia continuar estes ensinamentos de agora
essa senhora é dona de um hotel no luso
e portanto ela conseguiu rentabilizar o
que aprendeu nestas atividades para
informá lo em dinamização do seu pequeno
negócio e é isso também que nós
procuramos fazer é é sabido que a
fundação mata do buçaco tem em curso um
programa com reclusos portanto os
trabalhadores da nota tanto são pessoas
como nós pelo nosso e também são algumas
delas são reclusos mas nós nos
distinguimos umas das outras
como podem ver literalmente veste a
mesma forma e têm as mesmas tarefas e
também tem recebem é mesmo tipo de
informação formação técnica enquanto
formador enquanto bióloga eu comecei ao
longo do tempo a perceber que algo
estava a usar aquelas pessoas quando
chegavam a mata e depois quando iam
contactando com aquela realidade isto
despertou em mim uma crise nada e
recrutar uma aluna bastante corajosa por
aí comigo as prisões falar com os
reclusos de fazer uma investigação mais
do folha das ciências sociais talvez
este episódio informais de formação
teriam alguma repercussão da sua
obsessão do
e nas suas oportunidades de reinserção
social
e assim foi positivo já que dar uma
explicação técnica e científica sobre os
resultados obtidos nas ruas só decisivo
esta frase foi o recuso que agora é meu
amigo eu disse à senhora milan
eu fui um criminoso durante 20 anos só o
que eu aprendi aqui é que o fez
tremo deixar aquela viva eu era
criminoso tinha os negócios ilícitos e
elogia vive com o ordenado mínimo manter
o passo de ser milionário mas sofri uma
vida honesta e em comunhão com a
natureza e em condições bastante
precárias importantes pra mim impactou
no fundo é a final que aprendeu muito
mais com este estudo fio e não eu ea
minha urina clara bom entre outros
exemplos eu posso dizer que com toda
esta estratégia concertada dos vários
agentes
a mata do buçaco do público o seu número
de visitantes e sempre tanto sua gestão
depende das receitas geradas para surdo
menos de 100 mil visitantes para mais de
200 mil os recursos pedagógicos que não
estavam sendo apurados hoje em dia são
aproveitados por mais mil pessoas plano
que freqüentam o nosso serviço educativo
e tudo isto com base no conhecimento
científico porque eu acho que a ciência
é uma ferramenta para criar o
conhecimento coletivo e com isso
melhorar o bem comum e gerar
oportunidades gerando essa atividade há
oportunidades com as ações práticas e
como é conscientizar pode saber o que o
bem comum e as ações práticas não falou
do reino falar com as pessoas tanto eu
prefiro e o terreno falar com as pessoas
e agir com ações práticas grande
oportunidade e favorecendo a cultura
científica eo conhecimento para todos
esse episódio que vos contei passar a
noite na mata do buçaco
mas a importância da visita havia a
diversidade ea riqueza natural e social
não se esgota no muro que circunda a
mata há muitos tesouros por descobrir a
muitas regiões por dinamizar por
valorizar
portanto tudo o que eu vos contei se eu
pudesse eu tivesse que resumir
tudo empresa achava eu dizia que a
criança não tive as pessoas das
dificuldades que passei que ela não
sobrevalorizar as oportunidades embora
pequenas foram surgindo portanto eu acho
que devemos fazer daquela me dá a
oportunidade e valorizar todas as
oportunidades que surgem também devemos
aprender a agir porque às vezes achamos
que não posso mudar o mundo pop não
ninguém pode mas podemos mudar algo na
nossa casa nossa rua na nossa comunidade
usuária um pouco que saibamos para
proporcionar uma vida melhor aos outros
seja de que forma for pequenas ações
somadas vão fazer uma grande ação e são
as ações por mais pequenas que sejam que
vão mudar o mundo
o último é também portanto partilharem e
contribuir e fazer de tudo que saibamos
mesmo que sejam conhecimento empírico
uma causa comum que se destina ao bem
como portanto alguém todos não achei o
crescimento social
nós queremos valorizar o que nós criar
mais oportunidades a diferentes públicos
e transformar o saber é utilidade
queremos que todos partilhem e todos
contribuam
queremos envolver as pessoas as empresas
dos mais diversos públicos a
oportunidade que beneficiam todos era
uma valorização sustentável e acredita
em rede
ainda há tanto por fazer tanto por fazer
e portanto deixa o desafio se assim
entenderem se juntarem a mim nesta nova
fase do projeto que estamos engajados em
arco porque eu acredito
juntos vamos fazer muito mais e melhor
muito obrigada